let's go next to Brian from Ireland to
Brian welcome
hey David sir how you doing uh sir
welcome to the program
yeah first time caller thanks a lot
um I just want to say thanks very much
for for covering these debates um on the
live streams it's really interesting for
you know someone
um looking from abroad at the American
system it's pretty interesting thank you
and my question kind of relates to that
as well
um let's say if somebody in one of these
TV networks put you in charge of
arranging the debate what kind of
changes would you make to the format
because I and I think you're in
agreement with me here that it's
intensely frustrating you know there's
never enough time to yeah develop
candidates positions never enough time
to scrutinize
when Charlie Chris tried to ask DeSantis
some basic questions you know about
really served four years yeah just
plainly ignored him and that was allowed
by the moderators no pushback whatsoever
so how would you um arrange this kind of
thing so for first and foremost there
have to be exchanges between the
candidates and in last night's debate
between DeSantis and Christ Chris kept
trying to get DeSantis to say I will or
I won't commit to serving all four years
and DeSantis just looked like his brain
was malfunctioning and then the
moderator would jump in and say we have
agreed that the candidates will not ask
each other questions or address each
other they will only talk to the
moderator now the candidates seemed to
have insisted on that sometimes it's the
moderators and the organ is organizers
who put that in I think the way we're
really going to learn more is we need
longer periods of less structured back
and forth between the candidates bring
up the issue of abortion for example
frame it with a question and but then it
doesn't have to be a half hour but at
least allow five minutes of open back
and forth with the moderator being there
to be able to jump in and say well hold
on a second don't talk over each other
Chris just asked DeSantis this specific
question DeSantis can you answer that
and and sort of managing the
unstructured time to make sure everybody
gets their points across we would learn
so much more from that than from 60
seconds now you respond to me for 30
seconds but don't talk to each other
it's just it's too short it's not the
way we really make progress by talking
through a moderator talk to each other
but in a way where we can actually hear
what everybody's saying
yeah completely agree that's the
fundamental change I would make more
time on each topic and talk to each
other
I I don't see how anyone halfway
sensible could disagree with you on that
you know well I'm just one that it
seemed not to want it you know I think
they see it as very risky
the the last thing for me as well I also
wouldn't have a live audience there
because it sends into a thirst as well
but it was totally farcical yep
absolutely Brian from Ireland appreciate
the call
thanks David all right appreciate
getting to speak to some of you today
we'll go to a quick break and be back
with more show right after this